faubourg saint-honoré devant l'elysée l
arrivée du cortège présidentiel
l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron qui arrive
depuis son domicile un an exactement il
a dû partir il ya quelques dizaines de
minutes de la rue cler à paris dans un
véhicule gris une espace on voit
françois hollande qui descend l'escalier
qui est dans le vestibule pour l'instant
de l'elysée qui va sortir sur le perron
pour attendre son successeur savez une
image qui va beaucoup compter on va
scruter le moindre détail on voit la
voiture qui pénètre dans les grilles de
l'elysée normalement le président doit
être accueillie et la norme sera
respectée par le chef du protocole
frédéric billets exactement qu'on a vu à
il y avait plusieurs fois dit tout à
l'heure françois hollande emmanuel
macron dans la cour de l'elysée avec
françois hollande qui l'a t'on donc sur
le perron emmanuel macron qui sort de sa
voiture et qui va commencer à fouler ce
tapis rouge tapis rouge qui fait 60 m 1
exactement c'est sa longueur il varie en
fait la longueur varie en fonction de
prestige du rang des invités
c'est même une scène qu'on n'aurait pas
imaginé un an
[Musique]
nous sommes que ce repas est beaucoup
plus ambitieux ses prédécesseurs en tout
cas prend son temps
ça pourrait l'être
maître des horloges on a vraiment pris
jusque là sont en or qu il se rattrape
je pense qu'il essaie justement de
trouver cette ce temps politique qui qui
malheureusement se confond très souvent
autant médiatique et je pense qu
emmanuel macron cherche maintenant
une nouvelle manière de montrer le
pouvoir
[Musique]
on voit les deux hommes qui s'apprête à
rejoindre le bureau du président de la
république pour un entretien